>>Sam: I'm Sam.
I'm a fifteen year old girl and
digital media is my second life.
>>Hello.
>>I am
>>Sam.
>>Sam I am.
>>If it's a school day, I spend
just two hours on the computer.
If it was not a school day, I'd
probably spend twelve hours or more
on World of Warcraft, MySpace,
listening to music
while I draw or yeah.
>>Teacher: Good.
First thing we're gonna look at
today is the bone from every angle.
>>Sam: My typical day is I
wake up at six thirtyish.
I check my text messages and then
get dressed and go to school.
>>Teacher: There you go.
>>Aline: Samantha's
an excellent student.
She is very smart.
She's on the honor roll, does well
at school, off the charts in math.
>>Teacher: Now mezzo forte.
>>Aline: And, you know,
she's very musical.
>>Sam: I enjoy very
little piece of band.
I like listening to the
music and how we progress
and the songs we make
for our concerts.
>>John: Sam is a creative girl.
She, when you give her a
project or an assignment,
she thinks outside the box.
>>Sam: Hello, Plutonians.
Today's weather is going to be a high
of two hundred thirty
six degrees Celsius.
>>John: She is always using all sorts
of multimedia technology
to create projects.
>>Sam: What is Pluto's mass?
>>John: Always doing something
different than the rest of the group.
>>Sam: Correct!
Now isn't that just great?
>>For one of my school
projects, I had to read a book
and it was really boring.
I didn't really understand
half of it,
so I saw that you can buy the book
on the iPod and it reads it to you,
so you can like listen to the book.
>>Digital voice: Squire
Trelawney, Dr. Livesey,
and the rest of these gentlemen,
having asked me to write down--
>>Sam: And plus, it scrolls
and you can read it on it,
instead of just holding a book.
>>My first life would be me with
my friends and like going outside
and riding my bike and taking
care of my foster puppies.
Drawing, painting,
music and all that.
>>[Sam playing piano]
>>Sam: Digital media is my
second life because when I'm
on the computer, I can really
like do whatever I wanna do.
I can create whatever I wanna create
and I can be a different
person if I want.
That's me.
That's another one of my characters.
I play World of Warcraft
with all my friends.
See, this is my team and
right now, we have the flag.
That's what that icon means.
>>Aline: World of Warcraft
is a pretty interesting game
in that it's one of those
multi user online games.
So there's other people in there
from other parts of the world.
>>Sam: Our team has the
flag and they're bringing it
to our base to get a point.
>>Aline: You have to work
with other people to do this,
and so they're learning teamwork.
>>Sam: Right now, I'm going to
defend the flag with an ice trap.
That means if someone steps on
that ice trap, they will freeze.
>>Aline: And they're problem solving.
They're using the different tools
within the system to problem solve.
So I think it's very
educational in that way.
>>Sam: I like this,
'cause it's competitive
and it's really using strategy in
your mind, and it's not like clicking
on something and it's
killing for you.
It's like, you have to use your own
mind and figure stuff out your way.
>>Aline: Samantha is very much
intrigued with technology.
She was not the kind of female
child that was drawn to dolls.
She just has always wanted
to be on the computer,
playing with technology,
and is comfortable with it.
>>Sam: And action.
>>Courtney: Let's go
to the kitchen, girls.
>>Sam: When I was a little kid,
I was handed a video
camera for the first time.
>>And, action.
>>I'm kind of into
directing, you know.
I've done lots of videos with
my friends and I'm usually
like telling them what to do,
what to do with their
faces, taking the scenes.
>>How about you do it over here?
>>Tiffany: Sam is creative, one
of the most funniest people I know
and she's just cool in
every single way possible.
>>What does she have to say?
>>Sam: "To make it from scratch."
And then you be like,
"Betty Crocker style."
>>Courtney: She's a little bit
more advanced with technology.
She's taught me a lotta
stuff about it.
She's really smart.
>>Sam: So do you want this first
clip or do you want the second clip?
>>Courtney: The second one
looks more professional.
>>Sam: Awesome.
>>Courtney: Betty Crocker style.
>>Sam: I text more
than I call people.
Like no one calls anyone anymore.
If you wanna get hold of
someone, you have to text them.
Right now in my in box, I
have one hundred and fourteen
and it's ninety nine percent full.
>>Dave: Sam's definitely learning
social skills and able to connect
to more people that way, and she's
definitely learning future work
skills as far as learning
applications and programs
and just learning how to
manipulate the software.
>>Sam: My method of learning new
software is really trial and error.
If something doesn't work out, I
just go back and try something else,
and then just explore it until
I figure out what I'm doing.
>>Aline: Or just go
to the Second Life--
>>I develop online education for
Northern Illinois University,
and I was asked to help students
build a microfinance game simulation.
Most of my students are college
students and don't have a lot
of graphical background or multimedia
game development background.
So I said, "Well, you know,
Samantha knows how to do this.
If you need an extra hand,
she can come in and help you."
>>Sam: Then I can take this
one and I edit the object,
so the top would close in to make
it look like a different shape.
I hit taper.
>>Student: Oh, so you can manipulate.
Okay, I got ya.
>>Sam: And I made it flexible,
so that it would move.
>>Ken: Yeah, I just
wanna change my clothes
and appearance in the open sim.
>>Sam: Go to your inventory
and click create at the top.
>>Ken: You know, I can understand
how my parents feel now, you know,
taking advice from a younger
person, but I'm pretty impressed.
I kinda wish I knew some of
this stuff when I was thirteen.
Probably help me out a lot now.
>>Sam: Then you can
be a guy if you want.
>>Ken: Nice.
>>Dave: Sam just picks
up on technology so easy.
She'll just explore the application
or the laptop and the cameras
and just spend all day
at it, just having fun.
>>Sam: Yes, that was me.
I am Sam.
>>Sam I am.
>>So this is the end
of the video, so...
>>I saw this link for
a virtual piano.
It shows you what note to hit.
And I would write down the
notes on the piece of paper.
Then I'd go downstairs
and I would practice it.
>>[Sam playing piano].
>>For more information on what works
in public education
go to edutopia.org